well this was always a staple in our
house okay turning down the audio a
little bit it's a little loud
um green bean casserole sure
it is it is and my mom made a delicious
green bean casserole but it was pretty
standard right and so as the years have
gone on and my mom may uh bless her
Hearts not with us anymore but I just
started adding things you know and
because I like extras I like a little
extra so uh first of all I'm going to
show you what it looks like that was
really good in the oven because I wanted
it to uh to reheat okay so it's got a
lot of extra ingredients and the recipe
is online I call it Sherry's cheesy
green bean casserole with mushrooms
Bacons in them oh I see the bacon right
there
yeah so I brought the ingredients most
everything so you can always change your
add or substitute uh but I use two
cheeses I use a monterey jack and I use
a sharp extra sharp cheddar cheese okay
so I saute the onions and the bacon I
parboil the green beans fresh green
beans oh yeah I love that through the
can we use for the cans when I was a kid
right um for whatever works right and
whatever you have in your house and
whatever is easy for you and then I mix
the cream of mushroom soup which you
always you know sure and you can change
that too you can use vegetable you can
use anything
and of course the french fried I know
that's required those are the key ones
that you cannot change people the crispy
fried onions is a must all right and
then I also add fresh mushrooms because
for me I like the bulk of the mud yeah
it gives it a little hearty flavor right
and then you know then I mix it all
together and you you use the still by
the the recipe there's the recipe our
holiday cookbook on there with extras
yes with all the extras all right so we
have to we have to try it do we have
time we sure do okay okay
okay
thank you Nate there you go awesome take
a bite
this is eating I want to get a green
bean of course oh
do you like it
you can add oh my gosh is it it's got a
lot of substance to it yes using the
fresh green beans though because they've
got that crispness to them I love that
to each his own happy holidays Happy
Thanksgiving you can find the full
recipe on eightnewsnow.com as I said and
we also want to hear from you what are
your favorite recipes you can substitute
you can submit them at Pitts pix
8newsnow.com and we'll add them to our
good day viewer cookbook oh my gosh this
is so good yeah that thing disappears by
the end of the show I don't know where
it went no idea I promise everybody in
the studio they could have a bite
okay they'll forgive us just around the
green bean casserole
really do you like no I really do I'm
saying that no it's awesome I just I
love this beans